hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren retter
boccia spielen wir nämlich don't wait
what with super power dieser typ ist
wohl unser bus der uns irgendwas sagen
kann und wir können jetzt irgendwie
anleger dennoch mekka nach so ich kann
jetzt wieder ganz normal durch das spiel
durchgehend sie jetzt beispielsweise
hier dieses symbol und jetzt das war
sehr krass es ist immer tatsächlich sehr
schwierig items zu finden mit dem man
wirklich hinter 80 wir haben hier ein
schwamm für die tafel und den nimmt er
sich jetzt und das ist gar kein schon
gewesen sondern es war
irgendwie werden diese spiele immer
brutaler die nehmen wir jetzt mal als
nächstes altem einfach und gibt es nicht
baseball schläger mal wieder hier haben
hier prallen oder eine pflanze oder es
ist es sind es ist erst x-men
tatsächlich hat er gerade an pizza
gedacht ist der typ wirklich nix mehr
der diese krankheit oder wie hieß der
noch mal ich bin nicht so in dieser
ganzen super mensch bei hero das ist
nicht ob ich habe in der nicht so krass
drin aber ich weiß noch gar nicht was
ich gerade mache ich hab euch übrigens
einfach mal den ingame ton gelassen weil
ich dachte der passt eigentlich ganz gut
von dieser witzigen musik wir nehmen
jetzt hier einfach mal so eine brille
und kann er sich aufsetzen und
es war natürlich klar okay dass das das
war dass das mache ich auch mal meinen
baut wir haben ja auch boxhandschuhe die
er nehmen
nun geht er ihn wahrscheinlich jobs den
würde ich mal sagen ich weiß nicht was
ich hier zu kommentieren soll es ist
einfach nur höchstgradig brutal dieses
super power ist local player docs.com zu
unleashed 2000 jahre später nach 2000
jahren habe ich das ganze jetzt einfach
bei box zehnt irgendwie aufgerufen hier
soll es jetzt auch möglich sein dass sie
das geld nutzen können und muss sich
jetzt einmal das cape und er nimmt das
cape und fliegt hoch und er und er macht
jetzt tatsächlich wollte vielleicht noch
höher fliegen
ich bin begeistert ich habe jetzt
einfach mal thors hammer genommen um
seine komplette visage zu
okay das war gerade lauda nimmt sich
jetzt hier unten das geo 3 oder eine
tasche und hat in der tasche eine
taschenlampe und kann mit der
taschenlampe seinen chefs ganz klein
werden lassen der hin er der mir ist das
seegebiet ist das gar nicht sehen leute
wir haben hinten noch eine nagelfeile
oder ein messer oder auch eine
blockflöte tatsächlich das und autos
immer herkommt und natürlich ist es
trotz aller der also so reisig auch
jeden tag zur arbeit
wir haben es doch schon mit dem
laserschwert gemacht ich spaß tja com
ziehen mit der tollen macht er nicht
angeschnallt ihnen in der mitte durch
das ist ja super
spider man setzt auf jeden fall nein das
ist jetzt mach mal halblang er ist doch
schon längst tot wir haben noch einen
löffel den ich mal antreten kann und ich
weiß nicht ob es vielleicht der würfel
von transformers ist
es ist der würfel von transformers und
er wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
alles klar
ich meine was auch sonst und er macht
irgendeine dragonball attacke hier oben
ist noch die maske von ironman ich bin
okay ist es war ja es war definitiv
ironman wir haben neun von 13 kills ich
mache jetzt noch mal eben den tür hier
damit wir einfach nachschauen können ob
wir alle kills fertig haben wir haben
wieder ganz viele von meinen leuten und
die boxen jetzt alle auf ihn ein und
auch wenn es nicht schon genug wäre
boxen jetzt nochmals alle auch hinein
mein typ hier vorne schaut natürlich
schön zu und wir haben das auch
geschafft dann klicken wir jetzt eben
auf next und schauen noch mal ich glaube
wir haben ca alles durch haben zehn von
dreizehn kills und wir haben jetzt
vorhin schon gemacht die boxhandschuhe
und fehlt noch irgendwas auch wenn ich
hier einfach mal durchstreife sehe ich
jetzt nur sachen die wir noch machen
können die wir tatsächlich irgendwie
schon getan haben deswegen würde ich
sagen meine damen und herren das war es
von diesem download spielen kennt ihr
noch weitere von diesem teil mich
erinnert das ganze so ein bisschen an
dieser henry stick men reihe wo ich euch
hier einfach mal ein video verlinkt ich
habe ja von diesen download sachen habe
ich das schon mal ein paar sachen
gemacht ich fühle mich allerdings immer
so ein bisschen blöd wenn ich das
hochladen zeit so ultra brutal ist an
die allerdings sagt dass es irgendwie
witzig ist dann werde ich davon noch ein
bisschen mehr hochladen ansonsten würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen das
war es vielleicht recht kurz aber es gab
nur 13 sachen die man austesten konnte
und dann da habe dann mache
wir sehen uns irgendwann